So, I um my friend recently came to
Christ, maybe like a couple months ago,
and he's becoming a Christian. I think
he's looking into a Catholic church. I I
don't know exactly what church he's
looking into, but he often uses the
Bible to like attack like gay people or
LGBTQ people for it's, you know, I don't
agree with what they're doing, but this
is I think it's a wrong thing to do.
>> Yeah. Okay, let me answer that question.
We know the Bible says
transgenderism, LGBTQ, and all the other
alphabets abominations to God. All
right.
>> Of course. Yeah.
>> I'm now going to show you what I
discussed a while back. Was the Bible
given to Christians to use to bash
sinners, drive them further away from
God into the pit of hell? Or was the
Bible used was the Bible given for
Christians to use to win those sinners
over to the only lifestyle that can
benefit them, bless them, prosper them.
All you need to do is look at the
example of Christ. So guys, understand
what he's asking me. His friend uses the
Bible to bash homosexuals
because the Bible condemns
homosexuality. It does, but let me show
you the principle in scripture. Very
good question you ask me because I'm
going to show you Jesus's way. Okay? Now
watch here.
Here's the principle of Paul right here.
Pay attention to the answer to this
question because this is a very
beautiful question. 1 Corinthians 9:21.
Okay. In fact, let me add another one.
Let me add this one as well.
Let me do 31. Yeah, let me do here. Even
better. Yeah, let me start there. I want
to go to 31. I don't know. Should I
start 24? It's all right. Anyway, here's
the principle.
Watch here. Though I am free and belong
to no one, I have made myself a slave to
everyone, to win as many as possible. To
the Jew, I became like a Jew to win the
Jews. To those under the law, I became
like one under the law. Though I myself
am not under the law, I'm not under the
law of Moses so as to win those under
the law. What Paul is saying is, I
did all I could to avoid
every unnecessary obstacle
in order not to cause someone to turn
away from the faith and hate the faith
and push them further away from Christ,
but did everything I could without
compromising the truth to make Jesus
beautiful,
attractive, irresistible. So once they
fall in love with the Lord, then I can
tell them what their duties and
responsibilities are. So if I'm around
Orthodox Jews, I'm not going to do
something to offend them like eating
sausage pizza because then I know that's
going to cause them to stumble and
that's going to scandalize them and
they're going to hate me and hate my
religion because they're going to blame
my religion for my insensitivity. Okay,
you understand a principle here?
>> Sorry. As I'm doing this, I got to put
some water for the cat.
>> That happens often when my my friend
does that. They end up hating
Christianity and it's like that's not
the way to do it.
>> Yeah. Okay. Everyone understand what
Paul is saying you don't do. Why am I
going to go
and antagonize Orthodox Jews
by saying that their traditions are of
the devil or
by doing things that will scandalize
them like eating cheeseburgers?
Because I don't know if you know this in
rabbitic Judaism, you cannot have meat
and dairy together.
You cannot have meat and dairy together.
You have to have two sets of utensils,
one for dairy products, other for meat.
That's why Orthodox Jews, you'll never
have them eat a cheeseburger. Okay. Now,
knowing this principle, why am I going
to have a cheeseburger and stuff it in
their face, meaning rub it in their
face? That means I'm trying to
deliberately alienate them and demonize
them and antagonize them. Paul says,
"That's not what I'm here to do." But
here's the key with the homosexual.
To those not having the law, I became
like one not having the law. Though I'm
not free from God's law, but am under
Christ's law so as to win those not
having the law. Now, what does he mean
here? Let me explain. Very deep
principle.
The homosexuals, the lesbians could care
less for the law of God. could le care
less for the moral ethical standards of
God because if they cared about it, they
wouldn't be homosexuals or lesbians or
transgender
since they don't care about the law.
In fact, many of them feel like
Christianity
drove them away from any belief in God
because of their harsh judgment.
I will then approach them without
shoving the law down their throats like
your friend does.
I'm not going to come and say, "Look,
you homosexuals, you perverts, you
sodomites, you're going to burn in
hell." He said, "When I was with them, I
didn't bring up the law against them.
I did not
bring up the law to bludgeon them.
I didn't even use the law. What I did
was preach to them Christ and him
crucified. And I'm going to show you
that
to the weak, I became weak. To win the
weak, I met people where they're at. I
stoop to their level. Someone who's
weak, I didn't bully him. Someone who's
oppressed, I didn't add to their
oppression. I've become all things to
all people so that by all possible means
I might save some. I do all this for the
sake of the gospel that I might share in
his blessings. Now, so what would he do
to those who live lawlessly? Here he
says it. What did he preach? 1
Corinthians 2:2. And he's talking to
Gentiles who are pagans steeped in
idolatry. How did he first approach
them? Watch here.
So far with me, guys? Watch here. Let me
show you how deep this goes. And so it
was with me, brothers and sisters. When
I came to you, I did not come with
eloquence. I didn't try to impress you
with my philosophical, metaphysical
razledazzle,
my rhetoric.
Or you proclaim to you the testament
about God. For I resolved to know
nothing while I was with you except
Jesus Christ and him crucified. I came
to you in weakness with great fear and
trembling. My message and my preaching
were not with wise and persuasive words
but with demonstration of spirit's
power. I did miracles to show you that
just Jesus is alive. And I spoke about
Jesus and what he did and how much he
loved you. That he died on the cross
because he came to save you. See, that's
what I focused on.
That's what I focused on. So that your
faith might not rest on human wisdom but
on God's power. Now again, the
principle. Give me a few minutes to
unpack this. Don't cause homosexuals to
stumble
who do not really know the heart of God
and why God says homosexual is
abomination. Cuz he created their bodies
and he knows
what their bodies are designed for and
what will do irreparable damage to their
bodies. He loves them. He wants what's
best for them. But they won't know that
he loves them if you come as this
representative and bash them to hell.
Then they won't want to have anything to
do with that god of yours.
Even as I try to please everyone in
every way. For I'm not seeking my own
good, but the good of many so that they
may be saved. Here it is.
I am not trying to please myself. And
I'm doing all I can to
make sure I remove every obstacle in
front of them so they can see that God
is in love with them and knows what's
best for them. Once they trust God, then
they're going to trust God to know this
lifestyle is going to kill you. So this
is what I would tell your friend. And
I'm going to leave you with the example
of Christ.
Example of Christ. Go read the Gospels,
folks. Jesus would be invited to the
homes of tax collectors. Matthew chapter
9:es 9-13.
He would be surrounded by
people that the Jews thought were
unworthy to associate with people of
illreute. Reputation were shot. Sinful
women.
Women considered immoral, unclean to be
even affiliated with. It was these
people
that he would visit, these people that
would invite him, these people that
would gather around him. Now, let's let
me show you example. As Jesus went on
from there, he saw a man named Matthew
sitting at the tax collector's booth.
Follow me, he told him. And Matthew got
up and followed. Now, for a Jew to be a
tax collector, that was considered the
height of treason and betrayal because
you're working for the Gentile
oppressor, the pagan Gentiles who are
oppressing your people who were
controlling the land of your people and
taxing your people for what was
essentially theirs.
For you to work for them, you were a
Benedict Arnold.
But Jesus deliberately goes to this one
tax collector and says, "I want you to
follow me. I want someone like you to be
my disciple." Which would have been
shocking to the religious authorities.
Now watch. While Jesus was having dinner
at Matthew's house, many tax collectors
and sinners came and ate with him and
and his disciples. Now when Matthew says
sinners, he means not that
the rest are not sinners. He means
people that even other sinners looked
down upon and said they were wicked.
Individuals that other sinners thought
were so wicked that they would call them
sinners,
which is ironic.
Okay, everyone got it? What's the
context here? Sorry.
Who came to him?
Tax collectors. Who came to him?
Sinners. Who sat with him and his
disciples? Those that society hated
looked down upon. When the Pharisees saw
this, they asked his disciples, "Why
does your teacher eat with tax
collectors and sinners? Is any
righteous? Does he know any better?" On
hearing this, Jesus said,
"It is not the healthy who need a
doctor, but the sick." But go and learn
what this means. I desire mercy, not
your rituals.
Going up to the temple, offering
evening, morning sacrifice and incense
and prayer. That is mere ritual. What I
want is a heart full of compassion and
mercy. A heart that reflects mine
towards others.
For I've not come to call the righteous,
but sinners. And I'm going to come back
to this in a minute. But here's this
other example. Now, you're going to see
where I'm going with this. If you're
listening, you haven't checked out,
you're not bored bored yet. When one of
the Pharisees invited Jesus to have
dinner with him, watch her. Pharisee,
right?
He went to the Pharisees house and
reclined at the table. a woman in that
town who lived a sinful life. Meaning
she was
sexually immoral, fornicating woman, but
look at the reputation of Jesus.
Learn that Jesus was eating at the
Pharisees house. So she came there with
an alabaster jar of perfume. As she
stood behind him at his feet weeping,
she began to wet his feet with her
tears.
Notice she is
getting his feet soaking wet wet because
she's balling.
She's balling.
She's crying so hard she's gotten his
feet wet.
Then she wiped them with her hair and
kissed them. She wouldn't stop kissing
his feet and poured perfume on them. Now
watch her.
When the Pharisee who invited him saw
this, he said to himself, "If this man
were a prophet, he would know who is
touching him and what kind of woman she
is, that she's a sinner.
We righteous people won't even come into
contact with prostitutes and adult." No,
no, no, no. Because then we will be
defiled.
Okay?
Jesus answered him,"Simon,
Simon, I have something to tell you.
Tell me, teacher,
right?" Simon, I have something to tell
you. Tell me, teacher, he said. Look at
the wisdom of our Lord. Perfect. Has the
perfect answer for every question,
objection, and challenge. Two people
owed money
to a certain money lender. One owed him
500 dinari. That's 500 days wages and
the other 50. So let me use modern curs.
Let's say one owed him 500 bucks. The
other owed him 50 bucks. Neither of them
had the money to pay him back. So if
you're he forgave the debts of both. Now
which of them will love him more? Now
watch. Who do you think is going to be
more thankful, more grateful, show more
gratitude, and show more love?
the one who had more to pay or the one
who had less of a debt.
The higher the debt, the greater the
favor, the greater the grace, the
greater the love, the greater the
appreciation.
Right?
See the point? So he's saying, which do
you think?
Which do you think is going to love the
master more?
Simon replied, I suppose the one had the
bigger debt forgiven. Now watch. You
have judged correctly, Jesus said.
Now he's going to say, Simon, you're the
dude who thinks your debt is not that
great.
Then he turned toward the woman and said
to Simon, "Do you see this woman? I came
into your house. You did not give me any
water for my feet." By the way, this was
bad hospitality. Get any good
commentary, you'll be told that it was
customary that when you're invited, the
master of the house would provide water
and have his servant wash your feet
because open sandals, dusty road,
accumulate all that debris and filth and
dirt. He says, "You didn't even do that
for me.
You invited me to your home
and you weren't even kind enough or
respectful enough to provide water
for the feet of my disciples and myself.
But this woman,
she kissed
my feet.
She washed my feet with her own tears.
But she wet my feet with her tears and
wiped them with her hair. You did not
give me a kiss, which was the custom.
You greet each other with a kiss. We do
that till this day. To this day, Middle
Eastern custom, we kiss each other on
the cheek.
You did not even honor me with a kiss.
Look what a bad host he was. You gave no
water for our feet.
You didn't even respect us enough to
greet us with a kiss to make us feel
welcome.
Just like the Bible says, greet each
other with a holy kiss. You didn't even
do that for me.
But this woman from the time I entered
has not stopped kissing my feet. You did
not put oil on my head. You know how you
have, you know, you wash your head, use
hair gel. Well, their their hair gel was
oil to grease your hair to make your
hair right loose, right? You didn't even
give us oil for our head knowing all the
dust and the wind
that blew against. You didn't even do
that. But she has poured perfume on my
feet. Therefore, I tell you, her many
sins have been forgiven as her great
love has shown. But whoever has been
forgiven little loves little. Meaning
I forgive her because of how much she
loves me. But only God can forgive.
Especially a woman that he's meeting for
the first time because she didn't commit
any personal sin face to face, right? I
mean, he's meeting her for the first
time. The sins she committed were
offenses against God. By him forgiving
her, he was saying, "I'm the God whom
you sinned against, and I'm the God whom
you showed such love, and I'm the God
who will show you great forgiveness."
See what Jesus is doing here?
Then Jesus said to her, "Your sins are
forgiven." The other guests
began to say among themselves, "Who is
this who even forgives sins? I'm God."
Jesus said to the woman, "Your faith has
saved you. Go in peace." Now, how does
that answer your question? I had to give
you examples.
Notice Jesus, who's God in the flesh,
infinitely holy.
His holiness
didn't drive people away. His holiness
didn't make people avoid him. His
holiness didn't scare people off. His
holiness was so attractive and
beautiful, people could not get enough
of it. And every time he showed up, they
ran to be in his presence. They ran to
sit before his feet because his holiness
was so beautiful. and attractive. They
wanted more of it. And they knew he
would never be like the rest, embarrass,
shame, and disgrace them. They knew they
were safe in his arms.
>> Thank you, Sam.
Tax collectors,
sinners. When they heard Jesus was in
town, they couldn't wait to see him.
They would come in droves to sit with
him to be in his presence
because they knew he would never
embarrass them, shame them, humiliate
them, disgrace them. And he was such a
god where he didn't make them feel
so unworthy, so dirty
that in his presence
they would run from him. His beauty and
holiness such they would run to him not
away from him.
So then let me ask you a question.
If Jesus is perfectly holy and tax
collectors and adulterers couldn't get
enough of him and they were drawn to his
holiness, they were attracted to his
holiness and they would run to be in his
presence and sit at his feet because
they felt safe in his arms. Are you
being like Jesus when homosexuals and
lesbians
run from you and hate you and despise
you and what you stand for? Of course
not. No.
>> So then how's he being Jesus?
>> Yeah. It's not very Christlike. That's
what I tell him. You know
>> that's right.
>> So he doesn't so he doesn't do bad
things. You should just read the book
more, read the Bible more, try to act on
it.
>> Yeah. So what's the point here? Jesus
comes
to show compassionate compassion to the
sick in order to heal them and not leave
them sick. So Jesus meets the homosexual
where he is, loves him in order to earn
his trust and say, "Trust me. You know
I'll never hurt you. You know I'll never
embarrass you. You know I'll never throw
your past in your face. You know I want
what's best for you. Do you trust me?"
Yes, Lord. I trust you that I'm telling
you this lifestyle is not good for you.
Let me heal you.
Trust me.
This is a sickness. Sin is a disease.
It's multiaceted. There's multiple
diseases, right? Sin manifests in
multiple diseases.
Do you trust me?
Have I done anything to get you to doubt
me that I love you and adore you? I know
what's best for you. I know what will
harm you and I'm telling you this is
going to destroy you and harm you. Do
you trust me that I'm not here to hurt
you and shame you? Of course. Give me
your hand. Let me heal you. This
lifestyle is not for you.
That's how Jesus does it. Now, after
confronted with the heart of Christ and
the love of Christ, if they double down
and resist, now they're without excuse.
Now, the Lord will deal with them
accordingly. So, hope that answer your
question, man.
>> Yeah. Thank you, Sam. I guess I'll see
you on the live stream another day. I
just want to say thank you for your your
funny skits with the Muslim stuff. That
was really funny. Uh, thank you for
teaching really nicely. I love the way
you teach. Thank you, man.
>> Well, thank Jesus because I'm trying to
reflect Jesus's teachings and his heart,
though I fail to live up to it. May he
have mercy on me and pity me because I'm
sick
>> and I need to be in his hospital.
>> Glory to God. Thank you, man. Have a
good night.